[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم واليوم سنخصص هذه الساعه
لمناقشه مواضيع ضد صله مع الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه في ثلاثه اجزاء في
الجزء الاول نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
ماذا تعني حتى الان وما هي تداعيات
التقارب الكبير بين الحزبين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري في مجلس الشيوخ والتفوق الملحوظ
الاحمر على الازرق
في الجزء الثاني ما هو مصير قرارات بيضا
في القضايا الرئيسيه واهمها المواقف من
ايران والحرب في اوكرانيا والازمه الصينيه
خلال العامين القادمين وفي الجزء الثالث
ما هي ملامح المعركه الرئاسيه القادمه هل
حسمت لطرف على حساب الاخر بنا ان على
نتائج في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
اذا كشفت وسائل اعلام امريكيه رئيسيه عن
تباين في نتائج الانتخابات التشديد النصفي
فيما اتفقت على تقدم الجمهوريين في مجلس
النواب شبكه سينانا الامريكيه كشفت عن
حصول الجمهوريين على 200 مقعدا واثنين
مقابل
للديمقراطين في مجلس النواب في حين ذكرت
قناه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه ان
الجمهوريين سيحصلون على الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب بمئتين 220 مقعدا مقابل 2016
للديمقراطيه اما اي بي سي نيوز فقالت ان
الجمهوريين يحصلون على 2007 مقاعد في مجلس
النواب مقابله 188 الذي قراطيين اما فيما
يخص مجلس اشوي فقدنا الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
مقابله 48 الديمقراطين ايضا حتى الان وذلك
بحسب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
همم نسب اوليه همم وابدا من واشنطن معك يا
دكتور فراس همم حتى وانت بينت هذه النسب
وهذه الارقام ولكن تقريبا كل الوكالات وكل
حتى القنوات ان كانت تابعه للجمهوريين او
الديمقراطيين تشاركت نحو القول بان
للجمهوريين الغلبه على او في مجلس النواب
على المستوى العملي ما الذي سيغير همم فيه
ذلك
غلبه
للتيار الاحمر ولكن همم ما زال هناك خيبه
امل ايضا لدى جمهوريين بان الموجه الموجه
الكبيره تسونامي الجمهوري الذي توقعته
الكثير من المحللين واستطلاعات الرئيسي لا
هذا لم يحدث حتى الساعه يبدو انه هنالك
نعم تفوق للحزبه الجمهوري وهذا طبيعي
لنضعه في السياق التاريخي للامور في
الولايات المتحده غالبا ما يخسر الرئيس في
الانتخابات النصفيه هذا ما حدث مع الرئيس
اوباما مع الرئيس اوباما كانت خساره مدويه
خسر اكثر من 65 في الكونغرس الحزب
الديمقراطي يومها وايضا الرئيس الذي هو من
يعني اكثر الرؤساء الديمقراطيين شعبيه حتى
الان في الولايات المتحده كان هنالك اكثر
من 50 مقعد خسره الحس ديمقراطي فمقارنه
الهذه في المقارنه التاريخيه اذا اجريناها
الخساره همم خساره الحزب الديمقراطي في
الليله الماضيه لم تكن خساره مضويه
التوقعات لدى الجمهوريين كانت اكثر بكثير
من ما استطاعوا ان يحققوا حتى الساعه
امل الجمهوريه خليني انقل هذا التوصيف
للاستاذتهم حرب استاذ توم حتى وان كان
الجمهوريون مبدئيا متحصلون على الاغلبيه
داخل مجلس النواب ولكن ضيفي يرى بانها
خيبه امل كان المتوقع اكثر من ذلك كيف ترى
حضرتك الموضوع
اول مرحبا لك والزملاء الكرام والضيوف
هلا بالنسبه للخايبه امل
تست
طيع بالنسبه
للاحاديث التي كانت تقال منذ فتره طبعا
انه سيكون موجه حمراء وهناك ولكن الموجه
الحمراء سيكون لها ثمن كبير على سنتين
القادمهيتين باعين الناس وبنظر الناس انه
انتم اليوم الجمهوريين تتحملون مسؤوليه
البلاد ولكن القرار التنفيذي بيد اداره
الرئيس وهذه مسؤوليه كبيره ولكن ضل كان
مثل ما حصل ما سيحصل اذا مجلس النواب ذهب
للجمهوريين ومجلس الشيوخ لم نعرف حتى
الساعه يمكن يكون شيوخ بعد ولكن بدون هذه
الاصوات المضويه علينا كلنا ما بتحملوا
المسؤوليه همم جماعيه وانا بتحملوها
قانونيه بمجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ وهذا
فرق كبير للرئي العام الامريكي انه
المسؤوليه بعد عند رئيس الجمهوريه اما وين
ال- ال- التاريخ اللي صارت اصبحت بحكام
الولايات والمجالس التشريعيه المحليه كان
في كافح كبير للحزب الجمهوري بالمناطق
المحليه وهذا شيء جيد يعني يعطي دعم كبير
للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه بال 24
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه ولكن حضرتك سيد
توم تتحدث عن ايجابيات وسلبيات همم هذا
التشكيل او هذه المعادله الحاليه التي
نتحدث عنها ولكن ضعيف يا دكتور في راس
يقول بانه هذه الموجه الحمراء لم تتم هذه
الموجه الحمراء احدثت شيء من خيبه الامل
داخل اوساط الجمهوريين هذا ما اراد قوله
يعني الجمهوري اليوم لم يذهب الى التصويت
والى تحقيق الغلبه بما كان يتوقع للحزب
الجمهوري وهذا واقع استاذ توم
طبعا هذا هناك يمكن صوت ولكن يعني صوتوا
اغلبيه الناس على موضوع التضخم المالي
والوضع الاقتصادي ولكن هذا بدا منذ سنتان
يمكن اغلبيه المواطنين لم يشعروا بهذا
التضخم المالي اما حتى تصريف ناس من
اعمالهم مثلا صباح اليوم سمعنا انه شركه
الفيسبوك صرحت اكثر من 11,000 شخص وهنالك
شركات عديده ستصرح اشخاص هذا سيكون كمان
رده فعله بعد سنتين
حضرتك
همم ربما توجه الجمهوريين للتصويت ساعود
لك بخصوص مستقبل همم الحزب الجمهوري ولكن
دكتور بندر حضرتك على الموضوع يعني اليوم
نحن امام غلبه همم مبدئيه للجمهوريين
ويبدو بان هناك تعادل على مستوى مجلس
الشيوخ لن يكون هناك يقول البعض مفاجات
كبرى لا نعلم سننتظر لايام وحتى يقول
البعض لاكثر
لمحاوله فهم المشهد كاملا ولكن على مستوى
الارقام الحاليه قراءتك الاوليه
مجلس النواب وان فاز الجمهوريهم باغلبهم
متوقع ستكون اغلبيه ضيقه لان سالنا
الاغلبيه الضيق العاده همم لاحظ او طيب
توجد فيها اخليه تميل الى الاستقلال او
الى همم جمهوريون بعيون زرقاء كما لاحظنا
عندما همم
ستدفعه ربما للتعامل مع الديمقراطيين في
الحديث من الملفات وليس تحدي انا اجد ان
الجمهوريون الان ويفاز باغلبه خمس بقاعده
ما يتوقع المباراه اعتقد ان اغبيه لن تسمح
لهم همم بعمل الكثير او بفتح التحقيقات مع
الرئيس
وانحذف الجمهور على الجمهور على ذلك همم
نهايه بما حدث لرئيس السابق لكن اعتقد ان
اغلبيه ضيقه وخيبه امل الجمهوريين واعتقد
ان الجمهوريون الذي من همم هناك من يدعو
الى المضي قدما والنظر الى الاستعداد
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد خيبه الامل هذه
بخطب جديده برؤيه جديده بشخصيات جديده
واعتقد ان هذا هو المفترض طيب سنبقى مع
نفس هذا الاطار ولكن اسمحوا لي ان نذكر
بعض بالاخبار ذات الصله طبعا في اطار هذا
الموضوع هذه النتائج الاخيره مشاهدينا
تشكل حاله من الانقسام بين قادت وحكام
المجتمع الامريكي وهو ما قد ينعكس على
الثلاثه التي يدير بها جو بيضا البلاد
نتابع هذا المشهد ونورت
[موسيقى]
عاوز مش هتجيء الى ضيوفي دكتور مقصد اذا
كنا او سنكون ربما امام مشهد نهائي اااه
فيه الغلبه للجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
ويبقى الوضع على ما هو عليه في مجلس
الشيوخ يعني 50 50 همم كيف سيكون شكل
التعامل بين الطرفين فيما يخص القضايا
الاساسيه الى اي مدى بيض قادر على تسيير
السياسته على تنفيذ استراتيجيته بهذا
الشكل من المعادله الجديده
نعم هذا يعني هذا انسه ريم ان اجنده بيض
التشريعيه ستقف سينجح الجمهوريين حتى لون
يستحصلوا على الاكثريه في مجلس الشيوخ
وكانت كثيره اكثريتهم ضعيفه في مجلس
النواب يستطيع من خلال هذه السيطره في
مجلس النواب ان يعرقل اجنده التشريعيه بما
يتعلق بحقوق المراه بما يتعلق في
الاستثمار في البناء التحتيه المشاريع
المتعلقه بالتغير المناخي كل هذه مشاريع
اقتصاديه كل هذه الاجنده اجنده الداخليه
ستكون عرضه للتحقيقات همم يعني اللي
يعرقدت الجمهوريين امكانيه التقدم باي من
هذه الامور بطريقه جديه وفعاله في سنتين
من رئاسته الاولى ولكن ايضا من المهم هنا
يعني في قراءه المشهد السياسي والنتائج
الاولويه للانتخابات همم
او من خسر الواضح ان الولايات المتحده ما
زالت منقسمه بطريقه يعني المشهد مذكر اا
والملامح تذكرنا كثيرا في الانتخابات منذ
سنتين لم يتغير الكثير في المشهد السياسي
همم من كان الديمقراطيا بقاء ديمقراطيا من
كان جمهوريا بقى على حسبه الجمهوري لم
يحدث التغير الكبير اما في المواضيع التي
تهم الناخب الامريكي همم طبعا هنالك مقوله
شهيره في الولايات المتحده
ان الاقتصاد هو دائما الموضوع الاول على
ذهن الناخب الامريكي وهذا ما تفضل فيه
الاستاذ حرب وهو صحيح في هذا الكلام هذه
مقوله شهيره لجيمسكار وهو كبار المستشارين
للرئيس السابق كلينتون عن ما عندما
92 ان ان همم يعني ان ان يغلق الرئيس او
وقتها الرئيس جورج بوش الاب وكان سبب اساس
هو الاقتصاد ولكن الواضح ايضا ان موضوع
حقوق المراه وبما يتعلق بالاجهاض وقرار
المحكمه العليا في الولايات المتحده
بالنقد هذا القرار قرار تاريخي الذي يحفظ
لحق همم حقوق المراه في هذا الموضوع
الدقيق كان له وقعقا رئيسا في نتائج
الانتخابات ال- ال- الاقتصاد والتضخم كان
الموضوع الاول معظم الاراء استطلاعات
الاراء تاتي انه 32% من الناخبين
الامريكيين صوتوا بحسب اا رؤيتهم للاقتصاد
الامريكي ولكن 27 28% كان موضوع حقوق
المراه والاجهاض هو الموضوع الرئيسي هذه
الخطابات مثلت همم
شديده الخصوصيه في هذه المرحله ولكن سيد
توم هل حظرتك ترى بان التعامل صلب همم
الكونجرس سيكون كما تفضل بالاشاره الدكتور
مقص بمعنى انه سيكون هناك تعطيل
الاستراتيجيه بيدن او كما تفضل بالاشاره
منذ قليل الاستاذ بندر لما قال بانه سيكون
هناك تعامل عن مظف من الجمهوريين تجاه هذه
الاستراتيجيه للديمقراطيين حضرتك كيف ترى
بنسبه 70 ل 80% من المشاريع التي تقدم تمر
في الكونجرس من الطرفين وانما هنالك
المشاريع ذات الحساسيه هي التي يحصل فيها
تفاضل بين بين الفرقان هلا ما هي هذه
المساله مثلا موضوع العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي انا بتصور الجمهوريين ضد هذا
الاتفاق اذا حاول الرئيس مازن همم
المشروع من جديد بهم عندنا الميزانيه من
الميزانيه بمجلس النواه سيخ» ميزانيه
لبنيه تحتيه لمشاريع هون اما العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي بهذا الموضوع
لدعم المراه في ايران وتحريرها من الموجود
على باران اما اذا عم نحكي بحق حريه
المراه بقى انا ما بعرف يعني اذا الكومرس
اذا مجلس الشيوخ اذا كان من الجمهور من
الديمقراط سيعرض هكذا مشروع اما اداره بيض
كمان ستعارض هذا مشروع ولكن
سنرى تحقيقات من قبل الحزب الجمهوري واللي
جاي في
الكونغرس الامريكاني منها على سبيل المثال
كيف انطلقت كورونا من الصين بعد ما عرفنا
ما وصلنا النقطه الثانيه المنصات اللي مثل
جوجل وتويتر وكالهم يجب ان
نضع مشاريع اتجاه هذه المنصات وما هي حريه
هذه المنصات وثالث شيء عنتر بيضه يجب
التحقيق بملفاته
ومعاملته وتعامله مع الصين واخرانيا وهذه
الملفات فتبر على الساحه الامريكيه اما
بموضوع على الاجهاض والمراه يعني هي كان
صدمه من المحكمه العليا
انه ااه
صحيح
ولكن قالوا هذا مشروع يعود الى الولايات
ورايين نهار امثال امس اربع خمس ولايات
وافقوا على الاجهاض وهذا جيد يخلي كل
ولايه تاخذ من المسؤوله وتتحمل مسؤوليتها
وانا اتصور انه المراه الامريكيه ستعي همم
الفرق بين الولايه ذات الولايه اما هي
الولايه وخصوصياتها وحريتها ضمن هذه
الولاده
التحقيق مع بيضه فيما يتعلق به ملفات
كبيره وفي الواقعه الموضوع هذا دكتور بندر
فتح باب الجدل لانه البعض تحدث باسهاب عن
هذه التحقيقات في ملفات سواء كورونا وصولا
الى حرب روسيا اوكرانيا البعض ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك وتحدث عن امكانيه ان يعزل
بعيدا همم تيت كروز مثلا سنترا الجمهوري
تحدث عن ان هذا همم قادر ان يكون
فين اوباما المدافع عن بعد قال بانه اعتبر
بان هذه الا تصريحات شيء من الهرى هل يمكن
ان يصل الحال اذا كانت هذه التشكيله
باغلبيه لمجلس النواب همم ان نكون امام
تحقيقات وعزل في مراحل متقدمه
همم
واسعه قد تعهد ذلك ليس سرا انه اعلن همم
وبعدين هنا من الجمهوريون همم تايلوجرين
للنائب عن جورج نايف الجمهوريه المتشدده
واعلنت ليله امبارح انه صوبتهم عزل الرئيس
الامريكي بايدين وهمم نظرا لملفات كبيره
وقضايا كبيره من ملفات ولده وعلاقاته
بروسيا والصين وشركات الاجنبيه الانسحاب
الامريكي الفضيع من افغانستان
امريكي
المستقبليه نحن نعرف ان في عام 2014 2016
كان الجمهوريه يحققون في مقتل السفير
الامريكي في ليبيا وكانوا على مدار الاشهر
يفتحون التحقيقات ويعيدون التحقيقات
هذا ما اثر على الناخبين الامريكيين الذين
همم خلقوا موجه حمراء عام 2016
وانتخاب الرئيس الامريكي شعبه همم دونالد
ترامب وبالتالي انا اعتقد الجمهوريه الذين
تكتيك واسع وتكييف بفتح تحقيقات
كذلك يستبعد ويقول بانه هناك الكثير من
المبالغه في الحديث عن امكانيه عزل الرئيس
في هذا التوقيت على بعض سنتين من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وحتى الوضع في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا يسمح حتى
الوضع العالمي لا يسمح هل تعتقد بانه يمكن
ان تفتح تحقيقات وتصف ما بعد العزم
سوف يتم فتح تحقيق
كبيره واعتقد ان هناك عقلان من الجمهوريون
بما فيهم زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في ميس
السيوف اذا لم يحقق الجمهور الاغلبيه في
مجلس الشيوخ سوف ينعون عام عن هذا التحقيق
او لا يدعمونا رؤيه عزل ترامب هناك
في الحزب الجمهوري دائما يطالبون
بالمطالب متشدده او متقاربه اعتدل
العقلانيه ستغلب ال ال الحزب على الحزب
الجمهوريات وسوف يؤثرون همم
السيدظرون الحزب الديمقراطي على انه حزب
مقصر في حمايه الوطنيه
انفسهم الانتخابات القادمه طيب ولكن نقطه
نقطه نظاميه او نقطه قانونيه دكتور مقصد
اذا ما كنا امام هذا الشكل نحن دائما
نتحدث عن احتمالات في الواقع قبل خروج
النسب النهائيه ولكن اذا كان المشهد
باغلبيه جمهوريه لمجلس النواب 50 50 لمجلس
الشيوخ هل يمكن فتح تحقيقات حتى وان كان
مجلس الشيوخ كما نعلم بان نائبه الرئيس
يمكن ان تكسر في همم فترات او في مواقف
همم اساسيه يمكن ان تكسر هذا هذه المعادله
كما الهريسه نتحدث عنها طبعا يمكن فتح
تحقيقات
انسه ريمي يمكن فتح التحقيقات في مجلس
النواب نعم لانه اذا سيطر الجمهوريين كما
متوقع ان يسيطر جمهوريين ولو باغلبيه
ضئيله في مجلس انور سيتراس
يتراسون اللجان اللجان التي هي من تدير
هذه التحقيقات وسيكون كذا مقارتي هو قائد
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب سكن هو قائد
المتحدث باسم مجلس النواب فهذه التحقيقات
اذ كان بما يتعلق بنزل الرئيس
المتحده من افغانستان او حتى الملف
المفاوضات مع ايران وغيرها وجور سيكون
هنالك تحقيقات في مجلس النواب ولكن في
مجلس الشيوخ اذا بقينا على الحاله التي
نحن فيها الان اي هنالك انقسام كل 50 50
في مجلس الشيوخ ونائب نائبه الرئيسيه همم
يعني القاصمه ما بين الاثنين لم يظهر لن
يستطيع جمهوريون ان يتراسوا اللجان في
مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس الشيوخ سيكون معطل
عمليا بالنسبه لاي تحقيقات يريد ان يجريها
الجمهوريين ضد اداره
الخارجيه هذا ماسا نناقشه بعد قليل بعد
التفكير بان نتائج هذه الانتخابات
مشاهدينا ستشكل الى حد بعيد موقف اداره
بعيدا من قضايا خارجيه هذه القضايا من
بينها طبعا حرب اوكرانيا المواقف من
الصراعات في الشرق الاوسط اضافتا الى
الازمه بين الصين
نلقي نظره على السنر هذا المحتمله ومن ثم
نعود النقاش
عاوز مش راضيه
في ما يخص هذه القضايا الخارجيه وفي ما
يخص سياسه الولايات المتحده
الخارجيه هل يمكن ان يتغير شيء بتغير طفيف
نحن دائما امام تغير طفيف يعني حتى مجلس
النواب حتى وان كان الجمهوريون تمكنوا من
الحصول على
عدد المقاعد الاكبر ولكن هذا الفارق
الرئيس سيضعهم دائما
يخص العلاقات الخارجيه هل يمكن ان تتاثر
بتاثر هذه الارقام ام لا
طبعا العلاقه الزوجيه ستتاثر حتى لو
الرئيس لديها صلاحيات الكامله لنبدا مثلا
بايران اييه الملف الايراني مثلا قبل
الانتخابات وراينا بدا بالتعقيد من
المظاهرات في ايران والانتفادات الذي لها
تقريبا 50 60 يوم بايران ولكن لا راينا
النواب الاوروبيين يتفاعلون مع هذه
المشاهد وحتى بكندا ولكن بالولايات
المتحده راينا ال- ال- الديمقراطيين لم
يتجاوبون حتى الساعه مع هذه المظاهرات
ربما اليوم مع الكونغرس جديد فيتفاعلون
اكثر واكثر ويشرعون مشاريع لدعم المراه
ودعم المظاهرات في همم في ايران اضف الى
ذلك مثلا انتخاب بنيامين من الانترنت رئيس
الوزراء الجديد في اسرائيل يعني سيضع حدا
لسياسه يعني سفر
الابراهيمي عربي اسرائيل مع النواب
لجمهوريين هنا سيدى حدا للعلاقه بين الملف
النووي بين امريكا
وايران اما بالنسبه للحرب في روسيا يعني
كمان منذ اربع خمس اشهر بدا النواب
الديمقراطيين يعني يطلبون من الرئيس
بدعم مفاوضات مباشره بين توتنهام الرئيس
الاوكراني ولكن تراجعوا بعد شهرين من ذلك
الطلب انا بتصور اليوم مع الجمهوريين
سيكون طلب اكثر واقوى وواضح اكثر لوضع حد
لهذا الاستنزاف والذهاب الى مفاوضات لانه
ليس باستعادهم ان يذهب الى مجلس الامن
وروسيا هي من العرض الاساسي والدول الخامس
للبيته اما بموضوع الصين الكل المتفقين
على هذا الموضوع الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
لح تايوان من الصين اما الملف كوريا
الشماليه والجنوبيه كمان متفقين يعني
حزبين سوا ايه يحترق
وه يسمح لي ان اختلف معك وانقل لك ذلك راي
مراقبين ربما يختلفون مع وجهه النظر هذا
سيقول البعض بانه خطاباتهم تختلف افعالهم
ترتفق سواء ديمقراطين او جمهوريين في عهد
ترامب كما في عهد اوباما من قبل كما في
عهد بعيدا الان لم نرى رد فعل قوي ما رايك
دكتور بندر هل في الاتفاق النووي يمكن ان
تكون هناك
ضغوطات من جانب الجمهوريه كما تفضل
بالاشاره الاستاذ توم او كما يقول بعض
المراقبين الاخرين لا شيء جديد يذكر
اعتقد ان الجمهوريه يشددون الخناقه على
اداره
او تحديد العقوبات على النظام الايراني
حتى يتم التوصل للاتفاق او او حتى من دون
الاتفاق النووي حتى لو تمت وصفت التواصل
اتفاق النووي هناك تشريعات من اعضاء ال ال
ال ال الحزب الجمهوري من الجمهوري في مجلس
النواب والكونجرس
زعيم الاغلبيه في هذا الديمقراطي
يدعم العقوبات
علينا
العقوبات عند النظام الايراني
في اعفيها من همم العقوبات خصوصا بيع
النفط التناظر عن بيع النفط الايراني
للصين وروسيا وتدخل التدخل الايراني في
الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه عتاكد ان هناك
الكثير ملفات الجمهوريه توعدوا بفتح هذه
الملفات وليس سرا لانهم همم قد يصدمون
بالاداره باسرع مما يتوقع الجميع يعني
هناك ضغوطات ويمكن ان تكون ضغوطات قويه
فما يخص هذه النقطه ولكن فما يخص باقي
العقوبات كالعقبات المصرفيه مثلا او
العقوبات على قيادات الحرس الثوري وهذا
تعلم حضرتك انا الموضوع على طول في الحديث
لانه اساسا لا يعترف بالحارس السوري كذلك
قياداتها همم ربما لا تسافر كلها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا يفتحون همم حسابات
بنكيه همم في اماكن معروفه وخاصه داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكانه كلام
ولكن ليست هناك استراتيجيه معينه لمحاوله
اضغط على اراء فما يخص اما ملف حقوق
الانسان بداخل او كذلك حتى ملفات اخرى ما
رايك دكتور مقصد
كبيرا للتغيرات التي نشهدها في المشهد
السياسي في الكونجرس تحديدا على سياسه
الولايات المتحده وسياسه اداره بيدن
الخارجيه كما تفضل تم وقال ان الصناعه
السياسه الخارجيه في الولايات المتحده هي
من صلاحيات الرئيس والاداره همم وكل همم
يعني المؤسسات التابعه لها من البيت
الابيض من وزاره الخارجيه لغزاره الدفاع
وغيرها نعم هنالك تغير همم في المناخ ممكن
وممكن هذا ان يؤثر على الجو العام في
واشنطن ولكن نحن لم نشهد هذه الموجه
العاريمه الحمراء التي يمكن ان تؤثر بشكل
كبير على صناعه على القرار واخذها بعين
الاعتبار نعم هنالك من الممكن هو المتوقع
ايضا يعني يكون هناك حلقات نقاش مستمره في
القمر الامريكي همم يتعلق الموضوع في
ايران اوكرانيا او غيرها ولكن هذه الحلقه
حتى لو قدم مشاريع قوانين
في الكونغرس الامريكي تتعلق بها الملف
الايراني او المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا لكي تصبح اكثر من حبر على ورقيه
تحت وهذا طبعا لم يحدث مع الرئيس
فاعتقد ان ما سنراه هو الكثير من الضجيج
بعض من الضغط ولكن في نهايه المطافكر ان
الاتفاق انوي الذي ابرمه الرئيس اوباما مع
ايران في سنه 2015 هذا مثلا جمهوريين
يسيطر على كلا البيتين في الكونغرس
الانارب امريكا المجلس السوشيوخ ومجلس
النواب فعلينا يعني ان نكون واقعيين بعض
الشيء بالنسبه لتاثير هذه الانتخابات
وبالاخص ما يعني الاغلبيه الظهيره التي
نتوقعها لجمهوريين في مجلس النواب وعدم
الادراك الرئيسي سيفوز في مجلس الشيوخ
تقرير على السياسه الخارجيه في سنتين
المتبقيين من اداره هايلين سيكون كبيره
بانه وجهه النظر ان كانت جمهوريه او
الديمقراطيه قد تكون متشابهات تجاه قضيه
الصين ولكن البعض يقول ربما طريقه التعامل
الموقف ثابت هذا واضح ولكن طريقه التعامل
مع هذه المساله قد تتغير بين جمهوريها
ديمقراطي يعني مؤخرا حضرتك اكيد تبعت
التصعيد وكنا حتى البعض يتحدث عن اننا كنا
على شفاء حرب بعد زياره
بلوسي وحتى بعد حديث عن تسليح عن امكانيه
تسليح الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تايوان
هل تعتقد بانه مع هذا الفرق الذي يفوز به
الجمهوريون داخل مجلس النواب طريقه
التعامل قد تتغير تشاهد القضيه
لا بالنسبه الى الصين لا اتصور لانه بدك
صلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه فاذا هنالك فرض
عقوبات على الصين او اخذ مواقف مثل مكان
الرئيسي قبله الرئيس ترامب فرد توازن
تجاري بين الصين وحط مثلا رسومات اضافيه
على الصيد اذا الرئيس بيض لم يقوم بهذا
العمل انا لا اتصور الكونغرس يستطيع ان
يكون باي عمل وانما اسمحي لي بس ارجع نقطه
لايران في عهد الرئيس اوباما وكما تصدر من
اكثر كان هناك يوم متى همم كانت داخل
القومي بايران حوالي 600 مليار دولار لما
عندما اتى الرئيس ترامب وفرض العقوبات
وانسحب من الاتفاق نزل ال- ال- دخل ال-
ال- الايراني اللي حولها 250 مليار دولار
يعني معناتها العقوبات تفيد وتؤثر وهمم
الضجيج من ايران انه لم تؤثر همم هذا
العقوبات اثرت بشكل مهم واذا كانت استكملت
كمان ستؤثر ولكن نترجع كمان اخر نقطه هي
التاثير الكونغرس على اداره الرئيس هي
بال- موضوع النفط الداخلي يعني هذا الرئيس
يحاول الاطاحه بالنفط بعد كذا سنه كليا
وتكلم عنه مرارا وتكرارا وهذا سيضر تحت
غطاء المناخ تغيير المناخ الدولي فيضر دول
العالم كله من الشرق الاوسط الى افريقيا
التي تصدر فانا بتصور الكونجرس الامريكي
فيتحدل لموضوع التغيير المناخي والتعامل
معه من قبل اداره رئيس ايضا
دكتور بندر البعض يقول بانه همم في متابعه
هذه الارقام قد ايه قد يكون الهواء العربي
هو جمهوري رغم انه ليست هناك تصريحات
رسميه تؤكد ذلك ليس هناك تعاطي مع هذه
المساله يؤكد ذلك ولكن همم
لماذا يقول البعض هل هي مغالطه اولا هل
الموضوع يتعلق باشخاص اكثر منه باحزاب او
انه يتعلق باحزاب ولكن ننتظر كيف سيكون
همم المنهج فيما بعد يعني لو نفهم منك
اكثر كيف يتابع المجتمع العربي همم هذه
النتائج وما مصلحته مما اا وصلنا اليه فما
يخص هذه النتائج
العرب
نحن مرتبطون بالحزب الجمهوري نظرا لان
الحزب الجمهوري همم ربما يفهم قضايا
المنطقه افضل بكثير مما يفهمه الديمقرا
وكل مشاهدنا همم الرئيس الامريكي باراك
اوباما وقع اتفاق النووي عام 2015 همم بغض
النظر عن مواقف الدول العربيه التي عرضت
الاتفاق هذا الاتفاق النووي لا يمنع
النظام الايراني من الوصول الى القنبله
عندما يؤخر هذا البرنامج ونعمله نتحدث عن
العقوبات تجديد العقوبات نحن نتحدث عن
مشكله ايران انه ليس عقوبات من اجل
العقوبات ولكن ما الذي يحدث اذا اصبحت
ايران لديه قنبله نوويه الجمهوريين
يتفهمون ذلك الجمهرون الى خيارات عسكريه
الى منع ايران همم
بالوصولهم النوويه باستخدام القوه
العسكريه الاداب حتى اسرائيل كان في ضربات
عسكريه كما ده عسكريه
بالتالي
المواقف الجمهوريه تتفهم بمصلحه العرب
تتفهم القضايا العربيه
مخاوف الدول العربيه من التوسع من توسع
النظام الايراني بالمنطقه وبالتالي يعتقد
ان المساله هي مساله
[موسيقى]
للقضايا المنطقه اكثر من انحياز لحز ب عن
لماذا فشل الديمقراطيون دكتور مقصد في فهم
العرب كما فهمه الجمهوريون بحسب ما تفضل
بالاشاره الدكتور بندر
السياسه والتجاربات والصراعات في المنطقه
العربيه وبالاخص منطقه الخليج العربي ولكن
علينا ان نستذكر
عند جمهوريين وعند الديمقراطيين ولا ربما
بدا عن الديمقراطين مع الرئيس اوباما الذي
كان يكرر دائما معقوله انها سنون هي
الحروب الابديه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والانف والاذن
هنالك الدفاع للانسحاب من العراق تدريجيا
والرئيس اكمل الانسحاب من افغانستان ولكن
هذا الموضوع ليس حصرا على الديمقرا ابدا
بدل الناخبه الجمهوري ايضا لا يريد ان
يكون هنالك تواجد امريكي قوي في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط لعده اسباب والان اعتقد ان
ما نشهده همم الصراع الكلامي والنقاش لما
علق باوكرانيا ومدى تدخل الولايات المتحده
لمسانده اوكرانيا هو ايضا يعني من هذا
المزيج والمناخ الذي لا يريد للولايات
المتحده ان تلعب دورا كبيرا في سياسات
الخارجيه والتركيز اكثر على الداخل
الامريكي مع كل ذلك انا اوافق الدكتور
بندر الراي انه الجمهوريه متفاهمين اكثر
لدواعي ومصالح الخلفاء في المنطقه اذ
كانوا عربا ام غير عربي
الدكتور فراس والدكتور بندر ولكن اه بس
همم بانه في قوى ضغط ضمن الحزب الديمقراطي
ان كان من الاخوان المسلمين اما النظام
الايراني يلعبون دورا الفعاله ضمن الحزب
الديمقراطي ولا يستطيعون ان يلعبوه مع
المحافظين في ضمن الحزب الجمهوري وهذا
يعطي نتيجه همم متغيره مع كل اداره
بالنسبه للشرق الاوسط
الدول ومصلحتها من هذه النتائج ولكن ما هي
مصلحه الافراد يعني سيد فيما يخص مثلا
الافراد نعلم بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي على راس نظام عالمي نعلم
بانه هي تتحكم في العمله الدوليه الدولار
نعلم بانه بيدها ملفات كبيره ولكن انا
مثلا كعربيات في ما ستنفعني متابعه هذه
الانتخابات ونتائج هذه الانتخابات
يعني اول شيء بيهمك انت موضوع الديمقراطيه
دائما يتطور بالعالم الغربي حتى ينتقل
كمان للعالم الشرقي مع تطور الديمقراطيه
الابداع ينطلق معه التجاره الثقافه
الجامعات كله هذا عم يتطور مع بعض على بعض
وكل الدول العالم تستفيد منه بالدول اللي
بيقتاتوريه والقمريه ليس هنالك تطورا
ثقافيه اما تجاريا
امائيا اما من عشيا ساعتها العقل يقف
هنالك ولا يتطور ولا يتوصل الانبياء فلذلك
الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده مهمه
لجميع دول العالم لانه تعطي امل لشعوب
العالم
هي مهمه لهذه الدرجه ام خفت اهميتها منذ
فتره منذ سنوات يقول البعض منذ تدخلات
سياسيه تقطعات اخرى حسابات شديده
الامريكيه تبقى القطب الاكبر والمهم اييه
لنا كعرب عالم الفن عالم السينما عالم
السياسه عالم الاقتصاد
لا يمكن ادخيل العالم من غير تاثير
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن يعني
كشباب كعرب كافراد يعني بنستخدم المنتجات
الامريكيه مثل الجوال الايباد والمتابع
الافلام الامريكيه والتاثير الثقافي
الامريكي القوي على المواطنه العربي الى
محاولهم وتقسي ما هي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ماذا تريد امريكا من العالم
ثقافه امريكا كيف بنيت هذه الاسئله
بيدهن الافراد العرب بدهن الافراد الذين
ليس ليس لهم علاقه السياسه وبالتالي اعتقد
ان ال ال كل ما يخص الولايات المتحده كل
القوالب المتحده الامريكيه تهمه المواطنين
العرب تؤثر عليه سلبا او ايجاب ولهذا
السبب دكتور مقصد هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
اخذت كل هذا الاهتمام يعني وكلات قنوات
افراد ما وقع التواصل اليوم تضج بالمتابعه
وبمحاوله كتابه او نشر او اعاده تغريد ان
ساب والارقام
في الولايات المتحده في سنوات
اذ كان عند جمهوريين او عند الديمقراطيين
نحن نشهد هذه الجيولوجيا متشدده في اليسار
وايضا عند اليمين وهذه لا تسمح للسنتر
الوسطيه والعقلانيه لتاتي بسياسات همم
ممكن ان نتعامل معها وتعامل معها المنطقه
بطريقه جديه وانعكاساتها سلبيه جدا على
المنطقه الولايات المتحده هي القوه
العالميه الكبرى تاثير اقتصادي وسياسي
وحتى الكاوتش يعني ثقافيه تاثير كبير على
جميع انحاء العالم ليس فقط في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط اعتقد ان النتائج الاوليه التي
نشهدها ان هناك لربما
همم الحد من هذه الشعبويه الترابيه
والشعبويه ايضا عن ما يسمى الووك او حتى
اليسار
الايديولوجي عند الديمقراطيين فمعظم ال-
ال- ال- ال- المها جمهوريين الذين ربحوا
حتى الان يبدو انهم لم يكونوا من مناصرين
ترامب وترامبيه هنالك
جديد يجب
الى راوند سانتوس
للجمهوريين مع انه لم يكن هنالك مناصره
لهذا العام
من الاول كنت نقلتها للاستاذتهم كان صار
همم يعني همم اللقاء همم بينكم في ما يخص
هذا الموضوع ولكن في كل الاحوال هذه
المصافحه اولى ضيوف في الكرام والاكيد
باننا سنبقى في متابعه كل هذا الشكر جزيل
حضرتك من جد الدكتور بندر الدوشه البحث
على العلاقه الدوليه للاستاذتهم حرب
والدكتور فراس شكرا جزيلا
دائما السلام عليكم